what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest one punch man
chapter i am very excited with where the
story is right now and we finally get to
see what awakened monster god garrow is
capable of in this chapter and the story
takes a really dark turn with an
unexpected good guy death
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these one punch
man videos on the channel and want to
keep them coming the best thing you
could do is channel the cave baldy
within and smash that like button until
it's blue if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one punch man videos and while you wait
for the next chapter to drop
you can always check out my growing one
punch man playlist where i cover all
s-class heroes
all dragon and god level monsters blast
and a new video discussing how strong
garo actually is right now link to that
playlist is in the description
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and
all the cover page for this one is great
for multiple reasons yeah tatsumaki
looks super adorable in that outfit but
we also see
saitama flashy flash unwilling monster
friend and number one hero blast
who are traveling through space via
teleportation right now thanks to blast
partly this is a little sneak peek to
reassure us that they are going to join
the story eventually
but what really excites me is the fact
that blast is there
and in theory this is probably
foreshadowing that blast will appear
at least for a time while dropping off
saitama and flashy flash in the original
webcomic we didn't have blast showing up
like he did in the manga
and since a bunch of things are changed
anyways i'm really hoping for a god
level garo versus blast confrontation it
makes so much sense
it would be perfect for getting a sense
of blast powers and we all know that
garo would jump at the idea of taking on
the strongest s-class hero in his mind
that's like the greatest possible
achievement right now so although
nothing's for sure
this could very well be teasing that
confrontation which in all honesty i'd
be more excited to see than saitama vs
garo
but on to the chapter where we get
amazing visuals of garo's new form
as he screams monstrously bomb bang's
older brother
is the one to take him on first so
although not registered as an s-class
hero
bomb is a beast and he and bang are
considered to be the two greatest
martial arts masters
murata the illustrator of the one punch
man manga has said that bomb
is even stronger than bang before keep
in mind that was in 2017 and he's the
manga illustrator not the original
creator of the series so that should be
taken with a grain of salt
honestly i wouldn't put him above bang
but the fact remains they are more or
less represented as being on par with
each other
together they launched an attack strong
enough to demolish the initial
exoskeleton
of elder centipede while other s-class
heroes were having trouble scratching it
after witnessing this combined attack
genos called it the ultimate technique
so yeah it's not a stretch to say that
if bang is the number three ranked as
class hero then bomb is stronger than
most as
class heroes that's important to
understand before we can fully
appreciate this fight between
bomb and garo they start to fight and
the illustrations are
great the fighting is very high speed
and fubuki
can't even see it just like in the big
daddy of battle shown in dragon ball z
bomb lets us know that he's not gonna
hold back so
garo's new form is put to the test
against a character who is on par
with an upper s-class ranked hero using
his full power
in a pretty hilarious instance garo and
bomb suddenly appear in front of fubuki
who is shocked as i previously mentioned
because she couldn't see them at all a
second ago and now they're right in her
face
garo's fist almost hit her but bomb was
skilled enough to stop it and although
we can't expect
bomb to win against garo because it just
wouldn't make sense for the story
you gotta give him props for how well
he's doing against the self-proclaimed
god level threat
he not only saves fubuki here but even
manages to take the fight elsewhere by
hitting garo
deep into the distance he's clearly not
just being flexed on by garo
and can at times even take the lead in
the battle especially during the earlier
parts
fubuki is then asked by pig god to help
out tank top master who's still alive
thanks to the magic of the tank top no
doubt
and then we jump to the battlefield
where so many black sperms are occupying
a bunch of heroes including dark shine
atomic samurai and so on a giant
teletubby looking one grabs tatsumaki
keep in mind
it's insane how long this fight's been
going on and how often tatsumaki looked
like
she'd run out of steam so moving forward
we can't assume any of this
is her max power again we're told she's
got
a bit of psychic energy for protection
but not enough and black goes
to squeeze her before genos comes in
with the rescue
saving the op damsel in distress he then
gets
slapped to the ground only to jump back
up thanks to his
burial escape functionality this is one
of the things i love about one punch man
they actually think about the stuff we
constantly
see in battle shonen like someone being
beaten into the ground
and they come up with a funny
self-reflexive answer to it like burial
escape functionality
he even tells tatsumaki it makes use of
data from being hit by her as well and
she smiles and blushes although i like
the dynamic between saitama and
tatsumaki and i look forward to seeing
how that develops you can't deny there
is chemistry between these two as well
and their conversation is hilarious she
says he's lucky that she made him
stronger rather than apologizing for
hurting him in the past while jeno says
she needs to equip some apology
functionality
absolutely love that conversation back
to back these two
are about to take on countless dragon
level teletubbies when fury ugly returns
grosser than ever
not only does he look worse as he's
melting he smells horribly too
he's after revenge against silver fang
and he's deadlier than ever
as his melting skin burns you may expect
darkshine's polished skin to be
resistant but no it burns like crazy to
his horror
ugly is releasing strong acid and can
even spit it
he brings s-class hero darkshine to the
ground so yeah darkshine has not had a
good day guys for an s-class hero with
garo first and now this
s-class truly doesn't mean much when the
villains are on this
level ugly also lets us know that the
acid is a result
of the digestive powers gums gave him so
it's like a super gross but op
fusion in a sense then we get one of the
darkest moments in the series up till
now
that includes zombie a member of the
council of swordsman he pretty much
served as a hero who would in theory
help atomic samurai handle garo
here he gets acid to his face and it's
bad half of his head is dissolved so he
pretty much has to be dead
and for one punch man having a good guy
like this horribly killed is a pretty
big move
it seems like with this chapter things
have definitely gotten darker
atomic samurai and nichiren attack and
all that happens is their swords melt
away
this does not look good for the heroes
all around we return to the fight
between garo and bomb
and bomb is clearly tired and sweating
all over the place
he's 83 so it makes sense that he
doesn't have the endurance of the young
garo
bomb lets us know that garo has combined
every technique and refined them into
his own style
still he is determined not to fail until
bang gets there
and launches an attack that is
surprisingly cancelled out by garro
garo knocks him out with an elbow as
bang watches
clearly suggesting that garo has become
the strongest martial arts master now
but to bomb's credit he did last long
enough for bang to get there
bomb warns bang that garo is nothing
like before
and the former master and student make
eye contact and prepare to fight before
the chapter ends
what an insane chapter this was
i'm loving the garo stuff ugly is
definitely stronger than i expected him
to be
and all the while in the background we
have the knowledge that saitama and
blast could appear on the scene
any second plus we got one of the
darkest chapters yet
which could spell a change in tone
moving forward
this is definitely a crazy time to be
reading one punch man also back to bang
and bomb
clearly with this setup it seems that
despite where they were at their prime
bang is stronger than bomb because he's
fighting garo next
that's at least usually how it works in
shonen you don't tend to go from
stronger to weaker opponents taking on
the bad guy
still there may be some knowledge that
the former master of garrow can use to
increase his chances of doing better
than bomb did
it'll be interesting to see if this
fight happens now or if it gets
interrupted
by the appearance of saitama and blast
and i'm still really hoping for that
blast and garo match up it would make so
much sense to me and make me so happy
but that is it for this chapter
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming the best thing you
could do is channel the cape baldy
within and smash
that like button until it's blue if you
haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one punch man videos and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop you can always check out my growing
one punch man playlist
where i cover all s-class heroes all
dragon and god level monsters blast and
a new video discussing how strong garo
actually is right now in detail
link to that playlist is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
twigo himself
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
ingrata but they have the al-jatal dr
cortman the toasted chi
the spike emperor otaku spidey life
tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d quilly
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami and
water joey garcia ted no 10 fat boy
games cory mcgowan metal mama dudley
saint and soul right slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
anime upper and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do still get your name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll get access
to our private patron only discord where
we talk about manga chapters anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime opera link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to subscribe button
they've hopefully already destroyed a
lot of you guys have been doing that
which i love to see
so yeah you can definitely support that
way as well and whichever way to support
us you will get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you